[Music]
on this Saturday night school strike
solidarity
the growing battle between Ontario's
government and education unions pushing
for higher pay will Ottawa get involved
fight to compensate passengers for
canceled flights it's a new low
certainly the airlines are making a
great effort to pass off the risk of
canceled flights why Canada's two
biggest carriers say they shouldn't have
to pay you
plus the debate about black bears we get
to euthanization we've missed a whole
bunch of steps before that how our human
Footprints and climate change has caused
them to move closer to homes
and pull back snub to the king we won't
have any pleasure at all swearing That
Old Pub Allegiance the political push to
make a mandatory Oak optional
global national with far Nasser good
evening thank you for joining us
following numerous waves of pandemic
closures mask mandates and on and off
online learning this was supposed to be
the first semester with a sense of
normalcy for Ontario students instead
they find themselves in a state of limbo
once again as tensions escalate between
the province and some 55 000 educational
workers on the picket line for the
second day the Ford government is
pushing to deem the job action that shut
down many schools yesterday illegal but
workers remain defiant closing down one
of the country's busiest intersections
today young Dundas Square in Toronto and
receiving support from some of those who
are most affected in all of this David
Aiken has our top story
is an incredible turnout
it was dubbed solidarity Saturday
rallies like this across Ontario in
support of the Union representing the
province's educational support workers
in its fight with the progressive
conservative government of Doug Ford the
Ontario government is not paying these
workers correctly
without the custodians educational
support workers and secretaries that QP
represents many school boards though not
all shut schools and are moving classes
online and inconvenience worth the price
of making the bigger point for this
parent the people that were supporting
don't make enough money fairly enough to
survive right and we're from a higher
economic level in society right so we're
you know supportive of those that make
less
meanwhile lawyers for the province and
for the school boards themselves argued
at an Ontario Labor Relations Board
hearing Saturday that qp's work stoppage
ought to be declared an illegal strike
that should immediately end if that
happens QP could be facing huge fines of
as much as one billion dollars for every
week it's 55 000 members are off the job
QP argues its work stoppage is not
technically a strike but rather a
legitimate political protest to the
government's decision to override their
Charter rights to strike by invoking the
rarely used notwithstanding Clause we
cannot have a government
legal maneuver by the Ford government
using the notwithstanding Clause brought
the federal government into the fight
the Charter of Rights and Freedoms
cannot become a suggestion
it is something that has built Canada in
fundamental ways but sources in
Trudeau's liberal caucus say it is
unlikely the Prime Minister will go much
Beyond criticizing the Ford government
and will not invoke an even more rarely
used legal option that allows a federal
government to disallow or overturn a
provincial law in fact no federal
government has done that since 1943.
David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
amid the High Cost of Living and Rising
inflation the Canadian government is
looking to trim its budget by six
billion dollars in the coming months in
an interview with global news even the
Minister of Finance and Deputy Prime
Minister Christian Freeland says she's
tightening her own family spending
and I think Canadian families are
looking really closely at all of their
expenses I personally as a mother and
wife look carefully at my credit card
bill once a month and last Sunday I said
to the kids you're older now you don't
want to watch Disney anymore let's cut
that Disney Plus subscription so we cut
it it's only 13.99 a month that we're
saving but every little bit helps and I
think every mother in Canada is doing
that right now
for that and more details on the
government's newly released economic
game plan tune into the West block
hosted by Mercedes Stevenson tomorrow
right here on global if you are one of
the thousands of Canadians who've had a
flight canceled or delayed a case going
to the federal court of appeal may
affect you Canada's two largest Airlines
Air Canada and WestJet have launched
legal appeals challenging two Canadian
Transportation agency rulings which
found the airline's owe compensation to
passengers over flight cancellations or
delays caused specifically by crew
shortages Aaron McArthur reports foreign
travel has been turbulent full of
complaints missed connections and
canceled flights many of the delays
caused by short-staffed airlines not
able to fly all the routes they have
promised all the time
under air passenger protection
regulations Canadians are entitled to
compensation if Airlines come up short
in some cases up to a thousand dollars
each
but Airlines have been pushing back
against those claims according to
passenger Advocates it's little wonder
why the regulations are poorly written
with loopholes large enough to fly a 737
through what we are seeing here is a
failure by design it was created as a
kind of facade and reality
empty shell critics Airlines have now
reached new lows in their fight to erode
the protection afforded consumers
recently both of Canada's major carriers
were ordered to pay compensation to
passengers when the delay was caused by
crew shortages
something the Canadian Transportation
agency says is within the airline's
control
both WestJet and Air Canada are
appealing the airlines in separate
statements indicating they are seeking
Clarity from the courts
consumer rights lawyers say that Clarity
could become expensive everyone is
trying to pass the risk off to another
party certainly the airlines are making
a great effort to pass off the risk of
canceled flights onto consumers airlines
are arguing crew issues should be
considered safety issues
according to the CTA the regulations
state if an airline delays or cancels a
flight for reasons within its control
but required for safety it does not have
to compensate passengers Advocates say
if airlines are allowed to stretch
safety to include staff issues
compensation may never be paid it's
really creates a situation where uh a
test for a passenger can never be met
the CTA has its hands full
since May the agency has received 16 000
complaints from passengers
many of whom could be affected by this
appeal tens of millions of dollars are
on the lawn
Aaron McArthur Global News
two former presidents in the current one
are back on the campaign Trail to get
their party's candidates to the U.S
Senate
hello Philadelphia
U.S President Joe Biden and former
president Barack Obama are in
Philadelphia ahead of next week's
midterm elections while former president
Donald Trump rallies east of Pittsburgh
Jennifer Johnson reports
former U.S president Barack Obama has
been on the campaign Trail all week
final stops in Pennsylvania with the
power of the Senate on the line it's a
tight race here and both parties are
bringing out their biggest names to help
their candidates win John has been
fighting for other people his whole life
John Dunn just taught the top he's
walked the walk John fetterman faces a
strong Challenge from Dr mahmet Oz the
celebrity doctor made famous by Oprah
Winfrey although she is just publicly
endorsed veteran she's a nighttime I
mean it's it's unbelievable the
Republican party's biggest draw is
backing Dr Oz former president Donald
Trump who is also campaigning for GOP
candidates while hinting at his home run
for president in 2024. I will very very
very probably do it again okay the
fetterman Oz race is one of three
critical contests that will determine if
the Democrats can hold on to their razor
thin control of the Senate the other
matchups are in Nevada and Georgia
for incumbent Senator Rafael Warnock is
facing a strong Challenge from Herschel
Walker the former football star's
campaign has been rocked by allegations
of domestic violence multiple children
born out of wedlock and claims he
pressured some ex-girlfriends to have
abortions Mateo Senator why not don't
let that door hit you in the bright side
as you walk out of that room that room
don't belong to you sir that room
belongs to the people and you went and
watched it and you forgot about the
people that represented you
according to the U.S elections project
more than 35 million Americans have
already cast their ballots nearly 2.5
million in Georgia alone a record this
is huge as such especially in the Senate
and Congress right where power tilts
President Biden is optimistic Democrats
can fight off a red wave and hold on to
power in Congress polls are indicating
Republicans will take several seats in
the House but control of the Senate is
too close to call
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
and we will have full coverage of the
midterm elections next week from
Washington D.C As Americans head to the
polls
Iran is admitting for the first time it
supplied Russia with drones but before
the country invaded Ukraine
speaking to reporters today Iran's
foreign minister said they had sent a
small number several months before the
war started in February but denied any
have been sent since Ukrainian President
vlodimir zielinski says Iran is lying
about the number of drones sent
estimating his forces are shooting down
at least 10 drones a day
Russia's ongoing war in Ukraine in a
turbulent global economy has fueled
uncertainty in the lead-up to tomorrow's
cop 27 climate change conference in
Egypt leaders from around the world are
going to look at how they can reduce
emissions but many fear those efforts
will be overshadowed by the current
Global situation fredman Shannon
explains why finances will be one of the
biggest sticking points at this year's
event
in the years since cop 26 extreme
weather events have made sure the world
can't forget what is at stake when
negotiating on emissions since the very
first cop Summit a central tension has
always been that rich nations are to
blame for climate change but poor
nations are paying the heaviest price in
2009 it was agreed that more than 20
wealthy nations would pay poorer
countries to help them transition away
from fossil fuels and to help them
prepare for the effects of climate
change but the target of 100 billion US
dollars a year by 2020 has not been met
increasing the mistrust between the rich
and poor Worlds at cop 26 Canada and
Germany LED efforts to close the gap
they say the 100 billion Target will now
be reached in 2023 according to
Independent analyzes of countries
contributing their fair share Canada is
among the worst performers along with
Australia and the us although last year
Ottawa committed two double
contributions perhaps it's
going towards the right way but in the
context of needs of developing countries
this is nowhere near enough another
problem is that the bewilderingly
complex climate Finance process can
allow governments to muddy the waters on
their commitments this is really wise
everyone is saying what's very what's an
effect Etc it's because actually the
system is set up in such a way that it's
really hard to hold so many countries
and then so many actors so the private
the public that we discuss two accounts
reforms in financing will be on the
table in Egypt including making it
easier for poorer climate vulnerable
Nations to Access Financial and
Engineering expertise they don't have
the capabilities to formally to design
the projects to be submitted in order to
ask for the resources in Egypt there
will be more talks on what is called
loss and damage potentially to set up a
separate fund to help developing
countries recover from the effects of
climate change that they're already
seeing Redmond Shannon Global News
London
[Music]
there's my Advocates say it's on us
today people in Southwestern BC were
busy cleaning out from a fierce wind
storm that hammered the province's Lower
Mainland Sunshine Coast and Vancouver
Island overnight at the peak of the
storm Environment Canada reported wind
gusts clocking 70 to 90 kilometers an
hour in Vancouver the storm down to
dozens of trees and caused 330 thousand
customers to lose power
conservationists are sounding the alarm
over the number of black and grizzly
bears being killed each year in the
interest of Public Safety the recent hot
and dry Summers means bears are often
heading toward more urban areas in
search of food putting their own lives
at risk as Heather urac's West explains
Wildlife Advocates say more needs to be
done to protect the animals and their
habitat before it's too late
residents of this South Calgary
neighborhood were heartbroken this week
after conservation officers were forced
to lethally remove a family of four
black bears who had been feasting on the
area's trash I was angry there's been a
lot of chatter amongst the residents
that we need to do our best to keep our
garbage bins in and there's been so many
pleas from our Community Association and
Fish and Wildlife and
just people ignoring it it's it's
angering while killing Bears is a last
resort for Wildlife officers it happens
pretty regularly and the number of bears
destroyed each year because of public
safety concerns is staggering according
to government data in BC Alberta
Manitoba and the Yukon conservation
officers have euthanized more than 2 668
black bears since April 2020. we get to
euthanization we've missed a whole bunch
of steps before that which include
managing what's going on in people's
yards that prevents bears from being
euthanized with more people living in
areas close to Bare habitats there is a
growing need for more education and
enforcement so that bears aren't tempted
by dangerous Urban Treats but unattended
garbage cans aren't solely to blame
absolutely we're facing two crisis right
now we're facing a climate crisis and a
biodiversity crisis and they're playing
off each other the heat domes in recent
years have impacted food source sources
for Bears without available berries or
salmon stalks the animals have no choice
but to look elsewhere for food a
Manitoba government spokesperson says
the drought in summer 2021 led to a 60
percent increase in the number of black
bears it had to euthanize Canada will
play host to the United Nations
biodiversity conference later this year
with conservationists hoping the world
Spotlight will bring badly needed
attention and funding so these Majestic
animals are better protected Heather
urich's West Global News Calgary
[Music]
I had still debating that flu shot the
secondary benefits that might surprise
you
[Music]
with health experts warning the upcoming
flu season will be more intense than
previous years Canadians are being urged
to get their flu shot well now there may
be another reason to do so your next job
could help prevent a stroke that's
according to a new study from
researchers at the University of Calgary
which is now getting International
attention Sue lingo reports
stroke or a sudden loss of brain
function is the third leading cause of
death and a major cause of Canada the
best way to prevent stroke is with
healthy habits but could there be a
simpler method we thought you know what
about vaccination could there be a
relationship between people who receive
influenza vaccination and perhaps their
risk of Strokes that idea didn't come
out of the blue for University of
Calgary researchers there's a
relationship between
influenza and myocardial infarction so
heart attacks and so drawing the drawing
the links in with stroke was was a
natural Next Step they studied the
health records of more than 4 million
albertans over 10 flu seasons and they
found in the six months after a flu shot
when influenza protection would be at
its highest the risk of stroke was
significantly lower I wasn't surprised
that the effect existed but I was a
little bit surprised how how strong the
effect was and especially that the
effect existed for all adults all ages
of adults and all levels of Health even
those with chronic conditions seem to
benefit the researchers add any upper
respiratory infection including strep
pneumonia and covid increases the risk
of stroke or heart attack we know
pathologically that some of the
mechanisms of stroke are related to
specific bacteria or viruses that will
infect not only your lungs or your
bronchioles but also plaque and the
Carotid artery for example that me means
there is potential for other vaccines to
prevent stroke yet another reason to
keep up on all your shots what a great
added bonus here too that this might be
influencing your cardiovascular risk
profile as well suing Go Global News
[Music]
next forced to take the oath of
Allegiance Quebec M A's versus the
monarchy
[Music]
at some point in the days ahead 11 newly
elected members at the Quebec National
Assembly will swear an oath of office to
King Charles members of Quebec solidar
hope to avoid it but have been told they
won't be allowed to sit in the
legislature unless it's done they aren't
saying when because they don't want
anyone to see it tonight Mike Armstrong
looks at the political push to make the
oath optional
this ceremony had all the Pomp and
Circumstance of a regular swearing in it
was just missing one thing that meant it
didn't actually count the three newly
elected members of the parts quebecois
didn't pledge allegiance to the King
instead pledging allegiance to the
people of Quebec
quebecue Quebec Quebec they were not
alone in trying that end around to avoid
pledging allegiance to the new monarch
Quebec solidar elected 11 members in
last month's election and tried the same
Quebec well the speaker of the National
Assembly ruled Tuesday that the rules
don't allow those members to sit the
oath to the king he said is not optional
Quebec solidar now says it will
privately end reluctantly take the Oaks
despite calling it archaic and
humiliating we won't have any pleasure
we won't have any pleasure at all
swearing that oath of Allegiance but we
need to take our responsibility
now there may be someone new on the
throne but this isn't a new debate
members of Bernie levesque's government
back in the 80s added qualifiers when
they took the oath things like may God
help me
more recently black quebecois leader Eve
Blanchette took the oath to sit in the
House of Commons but says it was
insincere an oath which is pronounced
against the Free Will of the person who
has to say the words
is
Canadian politicians aren't the only
ones who've held their noses during the
oath this Scottish politician two years
ago crossed his fingers while swearing
allegiance to the queen
and in Australia earlier this year an
indigenous Senator took an oath and
called the queen a colonizer to the
colonizing Her Majesty Queen Elizabeth
Senator Thorpe she was asked to take it
again I'm going to wait for quiet
now when the new Quebec solidar M A's
retake their oath they have a first
order of business tabling a bill to drop
swearing allegiance to the king Mike
Armstrong Global News Montreal
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your Canada is
the sunset in Fogo Island Newfoundland
and Labrador and remember if you live in
an area that has Daylight Saving Time
tonight's the night to wind back your
clocks one hour until tomorrow take care
of yourselves and each other and enjoy
that extra hour of sleep good night